now turning to some breaking news out of
Japan where a passenger jet has caught
fire on the runway at Tokyo's haneda
airport local media are reporting that
Japan Airlines jet collided with a Coast
Guard Plane all passengers and crew are
reported to have been safely evacuated
from the a 350 aircraft emergency
workers have been trying to put the
blaze out for some time let's cross over
to Tokyo now Patrick ful is standing by
for is it has to be said Patrick that
the Japan Airlines staff uh should be
credited with getting what 300 79
passengers and crew off that plane while
it was still on
fire yeah that's right and it does
appear to have been a lucky Escape
because there are images showing the
passengers on the plane and queuing up
to disembark as it was being engulfed by
smoke and then there are images that
we're seeing as well showing the sides
of the plane being licked by flames
coming out of the passenger window so
really it does seem like this was a
lucky Escape as you say there are
reports saying that the Japan Airlines
a350 passenger plane struck a Japanese
Coast Guard uh aircraft we can tell you
that nipon TV is saying uh that there
were six crew members aboard that Coast
Guard Plane the captain is confirmed to
be safe but we don't know about the
others that were on board it's also
saying that the Coast Guard Plane was uh
in the middle of uh sending Aid to
Nagata as part of rescue efforts
following the earthquake that took place
yesterday so this really has been a
troubling last two days a troubling
start of the year for people in Japan
and Patrick Canada is one of two major
airports for the Japanese Capital we can
expect major disruption now can't we uh
at haneda airport certainly for the next
24 to 48
hours yeah absolutely haneda airport
really is the main sort of Hub that
serves as international flights in
particular it's to the south of the
Capal and of course there have been lots
of disruptions as a result of the
earthquake already yesterday things had
been getting back to normal to an extent
with transport links opening up of
course but you know as we've uh been
talking about today already I mean there
have has been considerable damage to
roads and that's hampered rescue efforts
to uh parts of the country that have
been badly hit by the earthquake and you
know authorities here have been trying
to uh support those recovery efforts
through other means and that would have
included uh via aircraft and the
Japanese prime minister has also
suggested that some recovery uh could be
done via ships to some of the hardto
access regions so you know this has
really uh been a step backwards if you
like uh we don't have too many more
details about how this happened exactly
but we will be looking into that in the
coming hours Patrick F there for us in
Tokyo thanks very much for the update
Let's cross over also to Alex macheras
an aviation blogger and journalist
joining us uh from London on the phone
Alex I'm think you're you're seeing the
same pictures that we're seeing of how
this incident might have
happened yeah exactly I mean this is you
know it's important to remember that
it's very very early days in terms of
trying to grasp what what could have
happened and as is often the case with
incidents what it appears in the first
couple of minutes and then hours and so
on can be very much different to what
actually happened and what we learn
later in the investigation process but
extraordinarily we are witnessing the
first whole loss of an Airbus a350 this
is one of the newest uh models of
commercial airline jets in the world
this pafic aircraft that was flying
today is just 2 years old and while it's
uh traditionally a l haul aircraft a
wide body jet to be flown across L haul
for most Airlines globally Japan
Airlines use this aircraft a little
different they are one of the only
Airbus customer custers to use the a350
for domestic flights and this was a
flight from saporo it was flying for
just over 90 minutes before making its
landing at Tokyo haneda and of course
the public broadcaster and local media
reports are suggesting that there could
have been a collision with a an aircraft
that was bound for the sites worst
affected by the earthquake so a smaller
Coast Guard aircraft is the line that is
being shared across Japanese media but
again there is little confirmation of
that at the moment the important
headline being of course the full safe
evacuation of the over 360 people on
board Alex let me just jump in there for
you because we're getting official news
certainly from uh a source in in Japan
uh it doesn't actually say who the
source is we think it's a a local TV The
Source at the airport saying the
condition of five crew members on board
the Coast Guard Plane appear which
collided with the Japanese air line
plane remains unknown we know that the
Coast Guard Plane as our pictures are
showing was on the tarmac as the uh
Japanese airliner was landing and it
seems to have clipped some part of the
Coast Guard Plane can we talk about the
evacuation process it is an absolute
miracle that uh over well 379 passengers
on that um Airbus managed to escape can
we just talk about how evacuations in a
scenario like this actually work well at
least Le one side of the plane is on
fire of course so we're already also
seeing footage from inside the cabin but
if I just give you some context to Japan
Airlines and safety this is an airline
that is absolutely forensic about safety
the safety culture at Japan Airlines is
industry leading and just two weeks ago
I was with Airbus and Japan Airlines at
Airbus headquarters in France and they
were showing me the new Safety Center
that they have opened Airbus have opened
in honor of Japan Airlines is focus on
safety that that gives you some context
and some perspective as to just how
rigorous and forensic they are with
safety so I can imagine that this
evacuation was absolutely textbook
because for almost 400 people to be
safely evacuated in those key first two
minutes because as if anyone is near a
screen now and they're able to see the
footage that we have across the across
all of the networks you can see there is
almost nothing left of this aircraft now
and it hasn't been very long that's why
that first immediate aftermath is so
crucial the footage from inside the
cabin we can hear the cabin crew they
shouting their orders reminding
passengers to leave all of their
belongings to head to the exits and so
on and so on ultimately the
collaboration between Airbus and the
a350 one of the world's most
state-of-the-art aircraft Jets um and
that has learned over years and years of
of different incidents and and things
that we've learned across Aviation
combined with Japan Airlines being so
forensic on safety it it doesn't
surprise me but it is also nothing short
of miraculous that we are we are hearing
that almost 400 people on that a350 were
able to be safely evacuated before of
course our thoughts are still with those
that the status is unknown of the other
aircraft that was involved that seems to
be a coast guard aircraft that's likely
to be much much smaller potentially less
than 10 on board but of course we be
waiting to hear confirmed reports about
that indeed if it is those five people
in terms of safety Alex um and we look
at these pictures and we look at the the
the Flames that have engulfed this
aircraft you know one does then ask
about the uh the fire retardant
materials within the main cabin and and
it brings me back straight to the 1980s
and the British Airways Manchester
Airport um crash which changed uh air
air design and the culture of the
materials used in the main cabin to be
more fire retardant uh and at a very
high standard and as you say you've just
been at a safety center there with
Airbus how much detail is there in the
materials that are used across the
industry in all the airlines when it
comes to upholstery because of course
the airlines want to make the flight as
comfortable as possible for the
passenger the airlines want to make the
flight as comfortable as possible but
also as we know airlines operate on very
slim margins so there is also a push on
financial efficiency and so many can
question you know does that ever
compromise safety well the answer is no
because air travel is the safest form of
Transport for a reason as an industry we
have the highest and tightest form of
Regulation and then when you move away
from the regulation and you just look at
the manufacturer airb for example in
this scenario before they've even
approached that customer Japan Airlines
Airbus at that Safety Center I'll take
you back there that I was there two
weeks ago have documented every single
from minor to Major incident that has
happened globally not just to their own
aircraft but to commercial aircraft and
we're talking about in history in the
100 Years of air travel that air travel
has been a concept and it is constantly
a learning process it is the highest of
of um highest level of Integrity when it
goes into that decision making to ensure
as you say that upholstery that cabin
design that the efficiencies of
passengers being able to move to the
exit but of course now with this a350
being on fire we are seeing the first
real world example of something as major
as an accident like this for an aircraft
that hasn't actually ever been involved
in a major accident this is the first
whole loss of an airb a 350 and so for
that first whole loss to have almost 400
passengers and crew evacuate safely that
immediately I think even though we are
only an hour into this is safe to say
that this is a testament to both the
aircraft and that collaboration with the
customer Airline Japan Airlines now
we're going to learn more of course over
the coming hours and days and
investigation will begin because we're
looking at an aircraft now that there's
almost nothing left of it now of course
that the big question there will be why
and only time will tell as we know the
full details and the contributors as to
how this all happened it will continue
to follow events throughout the night
certainly from Hana but for the moment
Alex mcis thanks for joining us from
London